so we have the volt valuetainment
polling analytics and you're going to
see that because we're going to pull
stuff together and and try to make sense
of it this is real data there's no jokes
here so let's start with Iowa and the
valuetainment too damn early poll we we
took a look at the last three
um reputable pollsters now they're not
always right but these are National
pollsters some lean left some Lee right
but they're real pulling grips signal
did it at the beginning of April
American greatness that right at the
second week of May and then right after
the Trump Town Hall uh a a three-day
poll was run by Emerson this is a very
reputable group again they lean left not
always right but they're reputable take
a look at this Trump went from plus
seven on the signal poll to 18 American
greatness poll to plus 42. look what
happened there and you look how pencil
can you explain it for people to see it
so if I'm looking at it look at Emerson
and go right across look at the dates
right 519 through 522 shows Trump 62
descent is 20 pence five Haley five Ram
zwani two and it says Trump is now up 42
so I'm going across while Tom is
explaining this go ahead yep and then
you go to American greatness that poll
was taken two weeks about a week and a
half prior about a week and a half prior
Trump was at 44 according to American
greatness DeSantis was 26 and Pence was
four and Haley was six or Emma Swani so
he and so Trump was up 18 on second
place to sanus and then the signal poll
that was at the beginning of April
remember beginning of April there's a
lot of media running around but neither
Trump or DeSantis had done anything
really huge and so Trump was
plus seven so there was a big pop now
that's Iowa which is a blue State and
the red part of Iowa is very dedicated
and remember that's Trump land that's
Middle America now let's scroll down and
look at New Hampshire in the too damn
early poll the New Hampshire two damn
early poll
the saint anslem ran it right at the end
of March Trump was 42 to Santa's 29
Trump was 13. then the University of New
Hampshire that's UNH right in the middle
of April April 13th to 14th they ran the
poll Trump was 42 DeSantis was 22 so
Trump by 20. and then American greatness
ran a poll right in the middle of May
but right after the clear American
greatness has nothing to do with Maga
make America great again it just happens
to have the same word correct they're
just these are just thank you very much
that's right just the that's just the
name of the polling group and Trump was
39 to Santa's 18. now in New Hampshire
there's the son of the former Governor
Chris sununu former governor and also
prominent in the bush White House Bush
senior White House John sununu so sununu
has got home court advantage up there
but look sununu in the recent poll was
basically tied with the Santa 17-18 and
Trump's 21 up on everybody and so it's a
little bit early but this is showing
Trump got a real bump and then we pulled
the by the way if you look at if you go
back up to that real quick look at
Rama's one he doubled yeah yeah you can
look at his moment you know they shut
him down on LinkedIn and then he came
back up with the LinkedIn he said
something uh oil or he's coming he's he
made a comment about fossil fuel and
Linkedin on the green side got all
pissed off and shut him off oh God and
uh let's look at just a real quick
National look now remember the primaries
is what matters so the reason we're
looking at States Tom get up there and
do your dance yeah
you can see here Trump is the purple
line at the top and the vertical line
there is May 11th that is the CNN Town
Hall
Trump gotta pop up after the CNN Town
Hall see there to to highest ever and
then you see he drops down a bit that
was seven days ago when desanta said I'm
officially running and I'm going to make
my announcement and then to Santa's got
a little bit of air in the room but look
at everybody at the bottom just kind of
bang around at the bottom Pence Haley
and everybody this is a two-horse race
but look at the trend line the trend
line doesn't look good for DeSantis
right now on a national basis now we've
just he does have a bump back up though
if you look at it slight bump back up
and Trump's gotta bump down since
Twitter spaces if you look at it right
and so we've got 60 days so ladies and
gentlemen value team at polling
analytics we're gonna be diving into
this stuff in a little over 60 days from
now actually closer to 90. we're gonna
be in August and Milwaukee and then the
Reagan Museum they're within 10 days of
each other in August the Republican
debates let's see if everybody shows up
because that's where we're going to see
all these folks on stage going at it so
if you like like this clip and you want
to watch another one click right here
and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]